All
[Music]
right. Should we get it going?
Let's do it.
All right. Welcome everyone. Uh this is
AI pipelines and agents in pure
typescript with master.ai.
Uh today's mission. Do you want to talk?
Sure. Um, so what we're going to do
today is we're going to build an AI
powered meme generator. And yes, that's
humorous, sounds like a toy, but the
patterns that we're going to use here,
uh, both with the master framework and
in terms of using TypeScript to build a
production agent are the same patterns
that that we've used and that you can
use, um, to deploy to production with,
uh, AI applications. Um, so the rough
format that we're going to follow here
is we're going to do like a 20-minute
intros and concept just to make sure
everyone's level set. feel free to, you
know, stop us, ask questions, and then
the majority of the the time this
workshop is going to be spent coding uh
together um collaboratively and then
we'll have about 10 minutes wrap up in
Q&A and a little fun demo for you at the
end to get some swag.
Yep. And uh yeah, so this is a true
workshop format. Uh we'll be building
together. If you have questions, uh
reach out to us. We're happy to help.
And uh just so you can get kind of a
head start on it, if you go to workshop
AI agents with Mastra uh the Slack
channel in the AI engineer Slack, all
the materials are in the pinned link
there and we can have discussions there
as well. Continuing
uh so we work at a company called work
OS. Um, we build developer tools and
make enterprise features happy,
enterprise developers happy with easy to
use tools like SSO and SAML, directory
sync, audit logs, fine grained off. Uh,
and we're really getting into AI uh, and
securing your AI. Uh, things like
securing your MCP, attaching identity to
those agents so that they can act on
your behalf and know who you are.
Yep. Um, another good way to think about
work OS is if you like let's say Nick
and I built the ultimate app this
weekend. We're ready to go sell it. And
then the first time we we demo it to
somebody. They say, "Can you give us a
single sign on for our 2,000 users over
here and a different path over here?"
Um, so then we would go and buy Work OS
or use Work OS, drop the JavaScript in,
and we would have those features uh
ready to sell.
Uh, so my name is Nick Nissi. I'm
developer experience at works. Uh, I'm
also a host on the dysfunctional.fm
podcast, formerly JS Party. Any JS party
listeners ever?
Nice. Um, I also do conference mcing and
speaking. Um, I'll be at squiggle
comping that. Uh, which is a dev tools
focus conference in Boston later this
year. Uh, I'm also a Typescript
enthusiast as you'll see. I'm a Vim user
by the way and I'm Nick Nissi
everywhere.
Hey everyone, I'm Zach. Um, really
excited to be here with you all. I've
mostly been an application and
infrastructure developer uh my career
but for the last two years I've really
been focused on genai uh MLOps and then
retrieval augmented generation pipelines
or rag pipelines. So um yep really
excited to be here and building with you
today.
Uh okay so what is Mastra? Um I I'll
just embarrass two folks quickly and
just point out that we have some core
master team members here. So this is
very exciting. So you'll not only be
able to get some assistance from us
hopefully, but also uh from the master
core team for any questions that go over
our heads. Master is a framework. Um and
so it's a framework for building, you
know, production AI applications in an
agentic manner. And these are the
components that we're all going to learn
and get hands-on with today in this
workshop and understand very well by the
time we leave here. So we're going to
build workflows. Just think of them as
composable and typed pipelines, which
are very exciting. Uh tools that you can
optionally use uh and give to agents.
Agents are like the interfaces that
we're chatting with. Um they're the
ideal interface for humans to work with.
And then the master framework does some
incredibly cool things out of the box
with batteries included that we'll see.
Um so not just, you know, a playground
that makes it super easy to debug
everything, but built-in persistence,
memory, observability, and even um
evaluation so that you can determine
over time how healthy your pipeline is,
which is critical for, you know,
successfully deploying an AI application
in production.
Yep. And we'll be we'll be focusing on
uh pieces of this. We don't have time in
two hours to go over everything, but
there's a lot of really cool tools in
there. Uh, so we're going to be focusing
on some core concepts for the uh,
example app that we're building. Um, and
we'll kind of understand some of those
building blocks as we get going.
Cool. So, let's start off. What are
workflows? Um, workflows are composable
pipelines. So, the way that I think
about this is I map it in my head
mentally to if a co-orker says, I just
keep on having to go scrape the site and
download people that look interesting
and look up their info and then take an
image and then write an email. You know,
that sounds to me like a workflow,
right? It's a pipeline of discrete
steps. You want them to happen in a
certain order. And as we can begin to
see with this example code on the
screen, you can even have control over
transforms that happen in the middle of
your pipeline. So the idea is you're
chaining multiple steps together to get
some work done. You can pass data
between steps. And then very
importantly, because as we know, LLMs
are incredibly powerful, but they're
non-deterministic. And so how do we rely
on their output? How do we coersse their
output into something that we can
actually build against dependably?
That's uh where we're going to validate
inputs with ZOD. But we're also going to
learn how Zod can even coersse uh at
runtime and then handle error grace
errors gracefully. But really the key
idea here is that workflows are a
discrete set of t steps to get a task
done.
Yep. And the the API is very similar. Uh
it reminds me of like RxJS like very
similar. you're starting with one thing
and then doing something and then
mapping to something else and then doing
something else uh and running through
all of that to give a little bit of
determinism to the the call of all of
these tools as they're being called by
your agent or some other tool.
Um and speaking of tools, uh tools are
just functions that agents can call. Uh
they can give you things like file
system access, API calls, database
queries, uh custom business logic. If
you've used MCP, uh MCP calls tools and
uh so that's like a really cool thing.
It gives the the LLM a the ability to
act on your behalf or to read in data
that it doesn't just inherently know
from its latent space uh so that it can
do more things and be more powerful for
you.
Yep.
Absolutely. to say that, you know, we we
think of like uh AI systems getting
better the more data and context they
have access to and and one of the things
that MCP is really excellent at doing is
is giving granting context to Claude to
OpenAI uh that it normally wouldn't have
and that's not in its training data.
Yeah. And one note for today's workshop,
we did build everything using tools uh
but then we switched as we brought in an
agent uh to call and we had the agent
call a workflow rather than the tools
independently. So we wanted to touch on
them there. there's something powerful
that you should look into on your own uh
and figure out your use case for them,
but we didn't really use them in uh the
final version of this workshop.
Um and then finally, what are agents?
So, we've all probably seen and used the
chatbot um type demos, but you know, the
way that we're thinking of agents these
days is really that they're kind of an
ideal human interface. So if I set up a
workflow that's a deterministic set of
steps to get some discrete task done for
my colleague. Let's say that my
colleague is in a hurry or they're busy
or they're doing this while they're on
the phone or they're not technical. Then
a chatbot can be an ideal interface for
that human colleague, right? Because
they can describe their problem or their
issue or what they need with natural
language and then the system can be
smart enough to actually do what they
want. And so this is the core this is a
very uh core kind of pattern that we're
seeing in in a lot of um AI
applications. And so we're actually
going to build this and understand this
here. So after we create our workflow,
we'll create an agent and we'll grant
that agent the ability to call the
workflow.
Yep. And agents was something that when
I first heard of them like like in a lot
of these things like the the naming adds
more confusion than is really necessary
and we spent like an hour on the phone
call and I kept being like but what is
an agent? What how is that anything
beyond just a simple prompt? And it's
really like the marriage of that prompt
plus the workflows or the tools that it
can use uh to do things in a specialized
way. Yeah, the other way I think of it
is like if you know in the past maybe 5
10 years ago you might have written
deterministic more deterministic
software with agents you're expecting
that the system overall can kind of
interpolate or can understand introspect
what's the state and then make a
decision um in like a graph sense of we
need to actually go here. So um that's
the other piece that you'll hear when
you're discussing agentic systems.
Yeah,
cool. Uh another thing MCP or model
context protocol I told you I'd show you
how to spell it. Um this is a way for
you to it's an open standard for a way
to bring like universal plugins or these
tools to AI agents so that they can be
called. Uh this was really developed uh
by anthropic and you can use it easily
in cloud code uh among other places like
cursor um windsurf I think uh and even
openAI is is adopting these tools as
well. So it's really a nice easy to use
API that these tools know how to use and
call
and to also make it concrete like you so
you work on the DX team at workwest.
you're constantly crushing a ton of of
bugs in all various SDKs and you use
cloud desktop, right? And so like what
changed the day that you enabled the the
GitHub MCP server for desktop?
The GitHub MCP server was the one that
really like made me understand what MCP
is doing because I was like why do I
want to do this? How is this different
than just like having access to GitHub
and and you know calling all of that?
But it's really an easy way for me to
have a conversation with Claude and for
it to bring in the context that it needs
based on the tool the uh issue that I'm
working on. For example, if you have an
issue on a a GitHub repo, I can just
say, "Hey, can you check out that issue
and tell me uh you know, here's my
example app. Tell me how I might
reproduce this." And it can like go
figure that out, pull in the comments,
understand what's going on, link out to
other repos or other examples from
there, and then uh look at my example
repo and tell me how to u to make that
change.
Speaking of MCPs, uh, we built a a fun
little demo called mcp.shop. You can go
there now and you can use MCP to order a
shirt. And it's the only way that you
can order this shirt. And for the low
low price of $0, you can get an MCP
shirt. The point is you just have to use
the MCP. So, it's just a fun demo to to
try out MCP, play with it. You can add
it uh it has instructions for adding it
into cloud or into any of the um MCP
servers uh sorry MCP clients that
support it.
Yep. Totally.
Uh also mentioned that recently so MCP
is you know one of the protocols that's
really hot right now in in the AI space
um and a lot of folks are are taking
notice. We recently had an MCP night and
it was at the Exploratorium. It was a
ton of fun. We we blew out like the
capacity of the event um and we had
people like lined up around the block
which we didn't expect. Um, we're almost
certainly going to do something like
this again soon. So, uh, be sure to
follow us if you want to hear about it.
Um, and yeah, we'd love to see you there
in the future.
Yeah.
All right. Um, what we're going to
actually build today though to to get
into it is the AI meme generator. Um, so
we're going to uh, if you imagine the
input to this is going to be you venting
any random frustration, workplace
frustration, frustration with your
colleagues or boss um, into the pipeline
and uh, the workflow will process your
frustration. Um, it's going to find the
best base meme that already exists that
would be ideal or might be humorous.
It's going to think about how to um,
actually edit and and create new
captions and it's going to publish a new
meme at a stable URL that's uh,
available for you. And again, I just
mentioned like this is a toy. We've got
two hours. It's a quick demonstration,
but the patterns that you see here and
the master framework are are definitely,
you know, AI um production ready. Uh
we'll use OpenAI just for the
understanding and image flip is the only
other API involved here which you can
get free uh username and keys for that
and there's information in the workshop
MD file for that.
Yep. Yeah. Yeah, and it's a really fun
demo just to kind of showcase some of
the tooling that you can do with Mastra
uh and how easy it is to really get all
of this going, but also not just to get
your your tools going, but to test them
very easily along the way. So, we can
start with just like a single step in a
workflow and test that without an agent
and then we can test the agent
independent, too. And we can do all of
this and not have to have like a full
picture uh to understand how it's going
to work, but kind of iterate along the
way. And the tooling that master
provides is just super nice. It's why we
love it. We're also huge fans of
Typescript which makes it awesome as
well. And so yeah, it's just nice and
easy.
Yep. Absolutely.
Okay, this is the way that we've
structured this uh workshop. And so, you
know, we weren't really sure the level
everyone's coming in at and some folks
are experts and some folks are just
getting started. So, uh it's self-paced
learning and you can go at the speed
that you want to go. If you want to go
and fly all the way through it, you're
free to do that. Workshop MD in that
repo is the entirety of this course and
so you can kind of follow along that
way. And then we also created uh git
branch checkpoints for you. So in case
for example you to fall behind uh you
get stuck on something and then we get
to phase two, you can also skip to phase
two and stay stay with everybody just by
you know get checking out the right
branch. Um if you get on uh if you get
stuck at any point, we're here to help.
So please raise your hand. We'll come
around and if you yeah if you have
questions that other folks likely have
or might benefit from in the future,
please be sure to come up to a mic and
uh we'll make sure that your question is
heard. Uh and then you know the other
way we're thinking about this this
workshop is again it's it's a anyone can
read online. We can all talk online
anytime but we're actually here in
person today. So you know please shout
out questions and raise your hand and
ask us things you want to know. Um we
feel that understanding is more
important than completing stuff here and
it's okay to explore. So
yeah we're all very new to this. This is
all very new stuff, very new tools and
it's very cool. It's also changing every
single week. So it's uh it's fun like
snapshot in time to play with this
stuff. Um, and if you have uh like I
said, you you don't have to finish it.
Uh, we do have the whole workshop.mmd
that you can follow step by step all the
way through to the end. Uh, and then
those those branches to um to get us
there. And if you just look at the main
branch, that's the completed version,
but it's more fun to build along the
way. So, with that, let's get started.
Um, like I said, everything is in the uh
workshop AI agents with Mastra channel
on Slack. So, if you're in there, uh,
you can go grab it. There's also uh the
get clone command right there to grab
the repo and uh we can get started with
that. Um just go to the stepstep zero
branch that has everything kind of as a
baseline to start from. Uh and then you
can npm install from there and get going
with the workshop workshop.mmd.
So here I think we can stop and uh you
you can get started. We'll give you some
time to build. Um but if there are any
questions um please come to the mics and
we'd be happy to continue the chat.
Hey, I had a quick question. Yeah.
Um, so the before you you showed the
example of an agent and it had
workflows.
That's kind of different from what I'm
used to seeing in these like agent SDKs
where they usually have tools. So is the
workflow kind of like a tool that I can
use or
Yeah, I mean to I like correct me if I'm
wrong here. I feel to some degree that
like the create tool and create step
APIs are are somewhat similar and in my
mind at least right now it's sort of
like an organizational preference. Like
if I have a simple um use case and there
might be three different tools and I
want the agent to decide the right time
to call those tools. I might create
three separate mostly essentially
functions name them tools grant them to
the agent and then start chatting with
the agent and ask for things and let the
LLM determine at runtime which which
ones to call. The difference is with the
workflow is I'm saying I always want you
to proceed in exactly this sequence with
these steps and these transforms. And
then you can also in master at least you
can optionally grant an agent the
ability to call that workflow. So and
also in my conversation recently with
with Sam that's kind of like you know
these are these are various tools that
you can build up and and kind of
assemble into the exact uh paradigm that
you need.
Can you do both tools and workflows like
I think so. Yeah, you can grant because
uh it's basic like you you're passing
like this giant gi JSON object to the
agent saying you can call these tools
and you can call these workflows. And
then the tricky part is like if you give
something a 100 tools and then ask an
LLM like you've got 100 tools. Let's
like go to Disneyland. I don't know
exactly what we're going to get out of
that, but that's where like the
determinism of a of a pipeline can be of
a a workflow can be beneficial.
Cool. Thanks.
Thanks. Great question.
Um anybody want to raise their hand? Any
uh there's no shame here. Anyone having
difficulties getting started? Um, need
help with that?
No, not at all. Uh, what's the
permission issue? I'll come by.
Yeah, the repo should be fully public.
Um, so should be able to clone that.
While Zach's doing that, I will also
bring up the um, Mastra docs
uh, because these are Oops. These are
wonderful. uh they're really easy to go
through, but also as uh Zach and I were
working, we uh discovered something that
was actually really awesome and that is
the MCP doc server. Um once I installed
this, things like got my tooling got a
lot smarter and knew how to work with
Mastra and it made things way easier. Uh
so if you get stuck or if not and you
want to see MCP in action, I would
recommend installing uh the master tools
for your IDE. I installed it into cloud
code and into um cloud desktop and
played with it in both and
it immediately knew a lot.
Okay, gotcha.
Can you clone with HTTPS? Can you clone
um not over SSH?
Try the HTTPS.
Um, so if you if you go back to the
repo, look at the GitHub repo like in
the browser, it should have a different
option.
Oh, you
want to So go to github.com works and
then master agent. You have to change
that from a colon to a for
grab this whole grab everything after
the amperand
at the sorry. Yeah. Grab everything.
Yeah. Go up here and so make but you got
to change the URL. So do https
and then github.com. Yep. And then
change. Yeah. Hit that.
Sorry, I'm having trouble.
Oh.
Oh, that's why. Thank you. Um, it
searched for that URL instead of going
directly. So make that
and then change this colon to for slash
and then get rid of that final get
that should go.
Okay. Now this see it there
should have that option.
Take this off.
HTTPS
because people are getting confused and
they don't have configur
uh any setup issues or
everyone everyone good
I'll post the http uh s clone command in
the
yeah thanks
uh in the slack as well
yeah In case anyone's having trouble
with um SSH clone cuz you're on a work
laptop, we'll put in the instructions
for HTTPS too.
Oh yeah, we're doing
we're
5 minutes.
All right, we're going to do about five
more minutes set up. Um, feel free to
raise your hand. Have an issue. Yeah.
Oh, sorry. What's that?
Oh, the Wi-Fi is bad.
Yeah, the comment is the the Wi-Fi is
bad. Uh, I wish we could do something
about that.
Sorry. Yes.
Classic conference Wi-Fi.
for cloud code. Yeah. Um you if you open
cloud code, you just need that you still
need that like JSON object, I think. I
that's what I use for my clients, but it
should Yeah.
All
right. 65.
going to do about two and a half minutes
until we move on.
Anybody have any issues? Everyone good?
Slow internet still. Okay.
Yeah,
we can give more time. We got
We'll do a queuing system. Everyone turn
off their Wi-Fi. One person download
packages. Move to the right.
Put it on a flash drive and then we'll
pass it around.
Yeah, that's that'd be sneaker net.
The repo is 77% cloned.
Nice.
This guy clones.
We will we can get more time.
Excellent. These are great numbers.
The end goal of this first step is
really just seeing the playground and
we'll kind of show that here in a
minute. Uh but it's there's not going to
be any tools or agents or anything yet
and we'll build those out. Uh but it's
just seeing kind of what Mastra gives
you right out of the box so that you
have everything you need to get going
fast.
Absolutely.
Let's go to 60.
Question 60.
Yes. Why why Mastro compared to all the
other frameworks?
I can tell you why I'm excited about it.
So, first couple of things I heard were
pure TypeScript, right? And I'm already
kind of bought into that with I like
compilers finding my errors before I
ship them. Um, then there's uh the
Verscell AI SDK that they I think that
the team wisely chose to build upon. Um,
my experience with that has been
excellent. It's kind of mind-bending to
kind of wrap my head around, but the
idea that I can multiplex between any
LLM provider. I mean when when GBT40
came out I shipped a two character
change in a PR and my entire pipeline
got way smarter and that was the day
where I was like this this SDK then I
found out that the you know master came
out and it was like verselli SDK and uh
pure TypeScript and uh I can tell you
that there's a ton of stuff that they
put in there like including evals that
are just uh baked in. So that's one of
OpenAI's own recommendations about the
right way to deploy agents at at
enterprise at scale uh is to start with
a evaluated pipeline. Um and I can also
I can tell you from working in like
vector database companies too that
that's people that are actually in prod
are using evaluations to determine the
health of their pipeline and the health
of each individual generation and master
has those baked in. So it's like import
and then like also evaluate my pipeline
and then finally so it's like because of
that um and it's on the versel SDK then
being able to deploy it quickly um and
then have a good experience that way too
and honestly what we'll see just in the
the local playground was
pretty great um okay yeah very complete
in my in my experience like every
everything has issues but that was the
experience I've had with it so far
and real quick uh I think that for me
like Typescript's moving fast with that
I still don't have figure out what PIP
is. So, it's prolonging that.
It's prolonging that.
Um, but also like we had, how many of
you have had these like come to AI
moments within your company? Like a big,
hey, we're going to have everybody we're
going to work hard with AI.
We're all doing AI now whether you like
it or not.
That Shopify post came out and then like
we had it. Uh, my wife's company has had
it. Like everybody that I've talked to
like, oh, we're going to have this
meeting where we're going to do
everything with AI. We're going to see
how AI can, you know, solve every
problem in every domain. And um after we
had that, we did like an open workshop
thing and we had uh like immediately we
showed Mastra and then we had like 10
people start going off with 10
individual demos and it was just like
fast and because they successfully built
the exact workflow they were looking to
build and so then for me the reason I'm
the most excited about that piece of it
is that I think it's an ideal platform
for internal tooling. I think all of us
are rapidly experimenting with this
stuff and you know do I want to live in
a world where Nick's writing bespoke LLM
scripts while I'm sleeping and I wake up
and I'm like what is this spaghetti mess
and he has to do the same with my you
know crap or are we all using Yeah. Or
are we all using like you know an actual
framework that we can agree on certain
primitives it makes us faster use
there's there's even forethought I can
see um in in the way it's been organized
so that once you've defined an agent a
different project can reach in and call
that agent via code or API. So, um, all
those reasons I'm kind of excited to use
it as sort of a unifying internal tools
platform, but we'll see. Yes. Yes, sir.
Yeah. Just a quick question on step.
This might be a little premature, but
um, step one, number five,
where you so you create a workflow, you
pass a discrete array of steps.
Mh.
Um, which of which there's only one,
which makes sense to me. And I would
think you would just I guess I'm asking
the the design decision behind then
needing to also explicitly do test
workflow. and then invoke the step. Is
that not implicit in the array of steps?
That's a good question. The commit the
ergonomics around are you asking about
the ergonomics around the commit method
itself? Like why actually
why explicitly say here's workflow and
what is going on with what's the
gentleman what's the decision behind
that? I'm just sorry I actually don't
know. Um I've looked at it recently and
I actually checked that API today
because I was curious about the same
thing as oh does it return I actually
argued with Nick because he correctly
said no it commit finalizes your
pipeline returns it and I argued with
him incorrectly. Gotcha.
So I'm not certain what's the what's the
final idea behind
commit?
It synchronizes. Okay,
got it. It's the final step that's like
actually creates the whole object and
adds the steps and returns the final.
Gotcha. But why? Sorry, I don't mean to
berate this, but like why the do then
and then the name of the step is that is
that step not already in the workflow of
steps already there.
So should be able to um so there's
there's sort of two ways of defining
steps.
Can you I'm sorry. Would you mind coming
to the mic just so sorry
I apologize.
So there's a there's two ways of uh
coming to of defining um steps. You can
either give it a step array um which as
you might expect is kind of um the most
a lot of times we just have these linear
pipelines of steps and so you can just
give it a step array and it will execute
things in a linear pipeline. Um or if
you want to add sort of like branching
and conditionals and a lot of that kind
of thing. Um we have this like fluent
syntax where you can do then and then
you can do if
branch do while and like loop and and do
conditionals and and all the fun complex
stuff
you know but a lot of times you're just
you're running through a pipeline. So
this
could you also just do test workflow
document and then
yeah yeah yeah
okay
for what it's worth I have also recently
had the experience where I had built two
different Gen AI apps like
experimentally internally and realized
that I had implemented a pipeline
concept in both of them and that was
another reason why I was like okay I'm
excited now about a single framework
with one pipeline
we're learning
yeah
we do have
Okay, we mostly got packages installed
or
waiting 200.
Nice. Nice. Okay. Excellent. And you're
selling access for $5, right? Okay.
I think we're
All right, we'll kind of show what's
what's happening. Um, feel free to keep
working on it. It's not uh you'll be
able to catch up quickly or you can skip
to the next step, which I'll show here.
Um, Whoops. All right. So, I'm going to
just um switch over to steps slashstep
uh one, which is the end of step zero.
That's where it would bring you to. Um,
and so
I don't know what's happening. Okay.
Nope, I'm not on.
There we go. I didn't know how to spell
switch apparently.
Um, okay. So once you have it all
installed, then uh you really should
just have kind of a master index. It
also has memory um set up for you
automatically. Uh but this just creates
the master instance. Um currently we
have nothing enabled, no agents, no
workflows, uh no tools and that's okay.
And when we oops when we run npm dev
uh we will get this URL localhost 411.
And if we go there
this nope this is this the end of step
one which is maybe there we go. Uh you
look here, you have agents, networks,
tools, MCP servers, workflows, and then
this runtime context. And currently we
have nothing in there. Um and that's
currently by design because we've done
nothing. We've just gotten the project
set up. But now we have all of these
tools to help us with building along the
way. And so
um once you get this set up, uh you
should be able to switch over to step
one or just continue on in your branch.
I think it might actually be the same
because it's just npm installing. Um,
and then you should be able to continue
on in the uh the steps.
This is I'll just say that this is one
of my favorite things though about
master like the local playground. And if
you look in the console, you'll see that
there is also a couple other things spun
up. There's the API endpoint. There's
also an swagger spec that you get
automatically. And so like the amount of
thought that's been put into this and
you can see how once everyone's
comfortable with it, you could you know
very rapidly deploy applications in a
standardized way that other tools can
consume uh reliably. So that's um
another exciting feature of it. And
again this is like without us having
built anything yet.
So the goals that we're going to do in
in step one now uh is just create our
first workflow. And this is just a very
basic workflow. we'll end up throwing it
away. Uh but it's going to be one
workflow with a single step and it's not
going to do anything else. But we'll see
kind of the power of it. Uh and then
we'll build upon that in the next step
to add additional steps. We're using
steps a lot. Um and then we will we'll
uh be able to put that together into a
full workflow in the next step,
but we we'll more importantly we'll be
able to see it in the master playground
and start really seeing the power of
that. Yep. testing.
As always, any questions, feel free to
shout them out. Anyone gets stuck, just
raise your hand.
Yep.
We'll run past.
We really tried to give ample time for
this, not uh not including Wi-Fi issues.
Um and so um yeah, if you have
questions, we'd love to to chat or just
ideas of this stuff because I think
there's a lot of really cool powers, uh
that you can do with this.
Sure.
Do you want to hop up to the Thanks.
Uh just kind of curious since you're
obsessed using Vim and kind of deep in
the hole. Yeah. Yeah.
Have you played around with any of like
the AI integrations in any of them? Kind
of like how what's your current
workflow?
Yeah.
Kind of adopting.
Thought nobody would ask.
Um yeah, I'm a big fan of Vim. I haven't
used cursor yet at all because it's not
Vim. Um
is Vim mode?
It's not great. Um but I have played
with the tools there. There's one I'm
forgetting. Goose I think. Vim. I
haven't played with that one yet, but
it's on my list to play with. Uh, the
one that I have played with is Avante.
Uh, which I think I have still set up.
Uh, yeah. So, it gives you kind of that
like chat like interface here. So, I can
just start having a a chat with this
code. Uh, I don't know.
There's was it Neoi used that for Neoim
even a year and a half ago. You could do
that before before most of the tools
allowed you to chat in IDE. Yeah. Yeah.
That's always going to be the benefit of
open source is it lands first, right?
Yep. Um, but I honestly like I didn't
like the ergonomics of playing with this
and like switching buffers and things
like that. And I honestly felt that uh
for me uh a better workflow was just not
using this at all. Uh I'm also a big
T-Max user. So um you know I will have
like Vim open and then I'll just open a
split and claude claude code um gives me
that kind of the same thing and it's
often like its own t-mux split. So I can
work in Vim as I normally would without
like weird buffer things and then it's
just off doing things and I can uh you
know oops use um use T-Mox to like full
screen Vim when I need it. claws out of
the way. And then when I want it, I just
bring it back in and go
I would also be interested in hearing
how all of you are using these AI tools
just for like not just what you're
building, but how you're interacting
with them dayto-day because they're
changing our workflows. And I feel like
everybody's like in their own bubble
doing their own thing. And then we like
we have this opportunity to come
together and learn like amazing new tips
and tricks.
Yeah, I'm all for that. I I don't know
that I'm all for everybody getting on
the same,
you know, plus
I think I think depend on on you know
product or or you know service or
whatever but um I'm I'm a feared of of
you know somebody coming down to high
with like this is the golden framework
everybody used this we've been through
that for decades
Yep for sure
absolutely
that's my personal
you like to mix and match and let
everyone kind of choose their own lane
that's exacting a
Yep same They're everywhere.
Yeah. To to summarize for the video,
mixing and matching tools is good. And I
think that that's really what is like
powering this right now, especially
among like us hackers, right? We're like
there's all these cool new things. It's
a whole new world of figuring out what
to do, how to do it, and you're not just
being prescribed, oh, just, you know, go
use random I don't want to shame any
specific editor, but like
anybody specifically.
Yeah.
But I mean, the leaders come forth.
Yeah, for sure.
You have those choices, you know. For
sure. Absolutely. In the meantime, I'm
gonna play around.
Yeah, it's all about experimentation, I
think. Yep.
Yeah, there's all sorts of
experimentation, all sorts of fun. Um
and and the the winners will bubble up
for sure. Um also, I I do worry that
it's like uh you know, the the first hit
is free and then we're we're all like,
yeah,
oh no,
becoming dependent on it now.
Yes, sir.
Uh question for you guys. Do you have a
framework specific like set of rules
like that would integrate not that
everyone has to use cursor but just like
all a sudden like um at my company we've
started to essentially say hey here's
the top 10 tools that we use and here's
cursor rules to do all those the same
kind of way and it's not so much trying
to like box people in but it's more
trying to say give them like in Mario
Kart it's like you get the the three
booster packs it's like how can we give
people people booster packs from the
Yeah, we were talking about this earlier
actually with Nick Taylor. Um,
we were talking about like cursor rules
growing and evolving kind of like tests
and then it's like this thing that
that evolves with your your codebase to
prevent you from doing bad things. Um, I
don't know what that means though
because I've never used cursor.
It's not exactly the question you asked,
but I will just say that that's also uh
like if when you run, you know, npx
install master, it asks you are you
going to use cursor, are you going to
use windsurf because if so, I know I can
inject the MCP server for our docs and
then the experience that I had after
accepting that I saw it's like oh it
enabled that I checked in my MCP in in
cursor and then that session where I
coded um there were zero hallucinations
and so that means that every time I
asked for a feature it was oneshotted.
correctly. Furthermore, because it was
in Typescript, I could quickly lint it
and compile it and know it was good. And
so that's almost like I we were almost
starting to Nick and I were starting to
suspect that MCP might be more powerful
because the other problem is that cursor
rules are specific to cursor, right? So
what if like half your team's on
Windsurf, half's on cursor, you know,
we've got tons of licenses for cursor
internally. So it's kind of like but
it's not prescriptive. I think the MCP
doc server so far is more powerful of a
pattern
because it is the it's almost like the
the guarantee that the end user dev is
going to get your latest docs is not
going to get a hallucination
and I really wonder if that's like like
there's so much excitement around that.
We saw that at MCP night a couple of
weeks ago. like there's so much
excitement around that and I'm I'm just
starting to wonder is it really just
because it's like a standard emerging um
and that's the reason because it's it's
very simple uh but it's it's enabling
all of these tools across you know it's
not just an anthropic thing anymore
uh which makes it super powerful
absolutely totally agree
yes sir
yeah I'm not sure if this is a better
question for y'all or for the master
team but I saw that mastra has
experimental support for ingest which is
a durable execution backend but that
it's labeled as experimental and I was
curious curious like how experimental
that is cuz I'm question really excited
about durable execution for agents. You
know if you've read the 12 factor agents
manifesto it's really good.
Oh no. Where's that? Who published that?
Uh it's on GitHub uh Dex from human
layer. Um originally did a lot of the
work on that. Um but yeah just was
curious about jamming on that.
Awesome. Great question. Thank you.
We have we have the folks in the room
for that. Okay.
Yeah. So Dex who shouted him out. He'll
be happy to hear that. Um uh so the
We shipped in uh sort of a what we call
workflows v- next about three four weeks
ago now. Um the idea being that
basically it allows you to have the same
syntax but switch out the the workflow
um engine. So the first um the the first
integration that we shipped we we sort
of initially had we initially built our
workflow engine using XATE as a backend
because kind of makes sense. Um, and
then we kind of we we need to make a
couple of syntax changes. And then we
also kind of realized that uh people
started asking us, hey, like I love the
syntax, but I'd love to have this work
with and I love the visualization in the
dev server, but I would love to have
this work with ingest or temporal um or
cloudflare work workflows or dot dot dot
dot dot. Um, and so we're like, yeah,
that's a really good idea. So then we
shipped workflow vx that was like again
three, four weeks ago. And then now
we're just starting to, you know, do the
list of integrations. So injustice
first. Um, it's you should use it. Like
it's experimental because we shipped it
like a week ago, but I would be
surprised if the API changed after a
week from now.
Thank you.
I actually have a question. Um, just
curious what how does the team think
about uh deployments going forward? Like
are you targeting specific platforms
first? Are you going serverless first?
Like are you thinking about trying to go
everywhere? Like what's top of mind for
you there? Uh so by default um by by
default like moss will bundle into a
hono server. Put the hono server in a
docker container and put it on EC2 or
digital ocean or wherever you want to
put uh put it. We also have adapters for
cloudflare um net or cell. We also have
on master cloud. Um we al so those are
kind of the two um you know the two the
we also like hono is not a you know if
you want to use hono great but also you
can put it in express or um what
whatever you can um you know put it in
the back end of a you know next.js JS
approator app you know uh in general I
think like you can't really I mean you
can call it open source and it cannot
work everywhere but like these days you
should actually make it work everywhere
so it's just our philosophy on things.
Yeah. Awesome.
Thanks. Yes sir.
Certainly. Yes.
[Music]
Hey
And then uh what's the full All right.
Oh, nice.
Yeah. What are your MCP shirts?
Such a fun demo.
74.
I think we're good.
Um, I had a question. So, I saw I was
just reading ahead a little bit. Um,
so I noticed that you spe you're
specifying like Zod schemas but also
adding instructions to the prompt um to
kind of follow that schema. Yep.
So I was wondering is there anything
sort of inbuilt into the framework that
ensures that the output of each step
matches the schema kind of by default
because what if like you specif like you
know let's say in the prompt you you
kind of forgot what your schema was and
you like how does it reconcile that as
well?
Yeah, great question. Um so I I think
the answer to that is essentially the
Zod schema, right? And the way that I
look at that is um like LLM are
non-deterministic. That's part of why we
love them. But then it's at the point
where they're so useful, we're trying to
get specific JSON out of them while
coding too, right? And the Zod um
package and and like validation library
is now ubiquitous in AI engineering, at
least in JavaScript. Like you'll see it
literally everywhere. So it's doing the
work under the hood. Um my understanding
is that the OpenAI team couldn't get to
a certain level of accuracy without
adding on top of training the ZOD uh
runtime validation which can also do
coercion into the right types. So that's
kind of doing the heavy lifting there.
Um I don't think there's anything
framework specific that's doing
structure generation but correct me if
I'm wrong but you can define like the
transform steps between the workflow.
Um, yeah, there's actually we actually
just did a blog post on this, but it's
funny that the models don't always
actually respect the schemas that you
give them, especially there's some, you
know, yeah, okay, Z.string, like they'll
respect that, but if you know, Zstring,
you know, length, you know, four or
whatever, like they're not necessarily
going to respect that like level of of
nuance. Um, so we actually added
uh we added sort of for for this is
especially challenging. This is mostly
works works reasonably well with
structure generation is more challenging
with with tool calling um for reasons
that are not quite clear to us but were
clear when we ran 16
uh you know uh 30 schemas across 16
models. So we added like a tool
compatibility structured output layer
that reduced that like reduce the error
rate a lot. Um,
so in addition on top of the Zod like
there's also master side like
optimizations to ensure structure
generation.
The the longer version of this is in a
blog post we published over the last
week if you're if you want to dive into
the the details.
And I I don't know if it's related to
this, but one thing that we were running
into constantly uh while we were
developing this was um we were like as
you'll see we were accidentally sending
sending like a B 64 encoded image uh
which was huge and and failing and it
would retry a lot. So I assume that
there's some retry logic built into it
to if like it wasn't getting back what
was expected from the schema. Um is it
built into the the schema validation
piece?
I mean I would assume probably what was
happening was that the agents has like a
max steps.
Yeah.
And so you was running until in a loop
until hit max steps and then
but it I I guess what I'm asking is if
you if you said I want a string that's
length four and I it gave back a length
five would it automat would master
automatically retry? There are cases in
which it would it would retry. I don't
know if that particular case is one of
them.
Okay.
Yeah.
Does that
Yeah, that does answer um my question.
And
to kind of to add to that with if you
were to specify uh certain things into
the schema that aren't inherently like
supported, for example, the the length,
would that
um would that be kind of er like would
that error just be displayed in compile
time at all?
Uh let's try it. I don't know. I I would
expect Zod to coersse it actually at
runtime.
Um but I'm not sure.
Usually the model will fail silently and
just give you a output that doesn't
conform to the
to the um to the uh to the schema. And
we kind of made a decision. Should we
error or not? And we're like
makes sense.
Maybe you should decide if you want to
error.
Yeah. All right. Thank you.
Thank you. Great question.
So just talking about deployment again I
I noticed the serverless deployments
there's no like AWS Lambda or anything
it's all through Netifi or that
um there's also an AWS Lambda um
deployer that the community had.
Okay.
If you if you Google you'll probably
find the GitHub issue.
Okay. And how does the the serverless
deploy work? Does each step kind of map
onto its own lambda function or how's
that?
Yeah, I mean we just sort of pack bundle
it in a in a in the a platform specific
way that works for those platforms. So
like Cloudflare has like a 300 meg um uh
bundle size limit and so we need to do
some specific things to get down under
that that kind of stuff.
I guess I'm just mean in terms of the
runtime model that each step kind of
maps logically to a function or are you
putting multiple steps inside?
single. I did not work on that part of
that. So, I would
I'm assuming they're all bundled into
one, but
I mean I think they are all bundled into
one,
but yeah.
Really? Okay.
That would just be weird for longunning
stuff because there's time.
I mean, yeah, that's Yeah, we I think we
we all we bundle it all into one, I'm
pretty sure.
Thanks.
Cool.
hard time.
How are folks doing on step uh step one?
Good.
Awesome. Okay. All right. We got
functioning Wi-Fi. Excellent.
So, we can kind of show that. I'll go to
um step two. Did I spell that right?
Yep. Uh which is the end of step one.
Um, and so now like looking at the code,
uh, we've got, if I update this, we've
now got our test workflow in our master
object. Um, and then we've got a
workflows directory with the test
workflow and the schema for it. And it's
just going to have you um, basically
extract from the user input uh, the type
of frustration that you're experiencing.
And the really cool thing now is like
without building anything else, uh, we
can go to our master playground, refresh
it, and go to workflows. And now we've
got our test workflow right there. And
you can see the graph here isn't very
impressive with just one step in the
workflow, but it's there. And we can see
that it would accept a raw user input
about work frustration. So, does anyone
have a work frustration?
Use your your boss by name, please.
Please state the company you work for
and your boss's name.
We won't tell them.
Conference Wi-Fi sucks. Not really. This
is a great job AI engineer.
Um, in general sometimes though. So, we
can see just by calling that it turned
green in the in the graph. And you can
see that we click on it. We can see that
that's the input that we gave. It ran
the step and it gave us back this output
this uh JSON object. Uh and we can see
with the text conference Wi-Fi sucks the
overall mood is frustrated. I think
that's accurate. Uh and the analyzed
frustration is technology. We're so
we're frustrated about technology in
this room.
So in the next step,
where did I go?
Oh yeah, here we go. Uh, in the next
step, um, we're going to create our
frustration schema with Zod. Uh, build
our first workflow step. No, that's what
we just did. I have my slides backwards.
In this one, we're going to, uh, create
all of the workflow steps. Uh, we're
going to chain them together with data
mapping. Uh, and then we're going to
successfully generate a meme. Uh, and
we'll understand the composition of that
workflow as we go. Uh it still won't be
like the perfect end result, but it will
give us the full workflow where we can
like kind of plug it in in that uh
workflows tool and see it go through all
of the steps from our user input to an
actual meme that's uh uploaded to image
flip.
So you can skip to step two uh or
continue on in your branch and uh
continue from there.
All
right.
I'm not sure what I'm looking at.
Uh, sorry. Can you repeat that?
I did the
frustrations.
Put in a topic, ran it, got back in the
boxes, highlighted
So I put it on.
Yep.
So I got a JSON object.
Right. And so what is this? Is this
something an object that I would then
pass to another pass on?
Precisely. Precisely. And it's just
right now we're just in the early stages
of showing exactly that and that you
could have structured this object
however you want.
Um but in our case because of the
pipeline that we're building, this is
the data that we found valuable. And so
we formed it this way and then we're
going to pass it further into the
pipeline to do more work based on that.
Yeah.
And so the output is
you can change it.
Totally.
It's your it's your arbitrary schema.
If I want markdown, if I want JSON, if I
want whatever.
Yep.
Yep. Absolutely. And that's part of what
Zotto will help you do too because you
can define like, you know, maybe you
have some giant object and you know this
many fields and this is a string and
this is an array of strings and all
that. Um but it's really for you to
compose together the exact structure
that you need.
You would have to know what the next
stage is.
Yeah.
So, there's a little bit of forethought.
Absolutely. The forethought or the third
time you've written that app.
You've had enough. You've had two shitty
first drafts and you're ready for the
third. Um, sometimes I do it that way.
But yeah, sometimes I'll plan it out and
be like, what's the logical breakdown
for these steps? Yeah.
Yep.
Yep. The main point of this one is to
just determine like the level of
frustration and what you're frustrated
about so that it can be fed in in the
next step to uh image flips API to get
back an an image template um that or a
meme template that would accurately fit
that and then we kind of shoehorn it in
from there. But the but again the the
like I guess the mental mapping that
we're all trying to do here too is like
to think about how do we take this home
then like turn it into something that
actually solves a problem or automates
something at work so we get promoted
before the machines come for us you know
that's the general
race
pretty much
human race
yeah I think so
and just so we're level setting this is
like the memes that you've seen image
flip is a they have an API I for not
only finding great memes uh but also
just having blank templates so they they
can give us back information about this
the rock meme the rock uh in a taxi meme
or whatever and those boxes are blank
and then you can post to their API with
whatever you want it to say in each of
those and it'll tell tell you like oh I
have three boxes and uh then you just
post in there and that's what we're
eventually going to be doing in one of
these steps
but that that's a perfect real world
example. It's like knowing those box
slots is critical to the rest of the
pipeline. If any other step in the
pipeline didn't know the box slots
correctly, right, like that would be a
problem. So you can define that in your
schema and make sure that it's there and
like that's part of it. Yeah.
Okay.
Yep.
putting this workflow together too is
probably the biggest of the steps. Y
um once we have this, we'll we'll create
an agent in the next one and that's
pretty straightforward uh as you'll see.
Um, and so there's there's time built in
also to to play with this, experiment,
tweak things like the um like the prompt
temperature
temperature things like that.
We we'll look at that in the playground.
That's the cool thing is like once we
get the agent start chatting with it um
you know like there's just a iterating
locally is so much faster, right? And
that's really what the the playground's
about. So you can even tweak the prompt
on a per request basis. You can change
temperature model, whatever.
Certainly. Yep.
That's what I
try that other trick.
I don't know what it
Correct.
result.
Please.
We got this.
Nope.
Okay.
Okay. So, I need to go
Does it sound like the credentials are
being?
Yeah. So, in general, if you get an
error uh at the generate meme step and
you don't get a clear error message and
you have not created an image flip
username and password, that's likely the
problem.
I did it first.
Sweet.
All right. And then if you sign in with
Google, which is the same thing I did,
that's fine. And then you just have to
go into image flip settings after and
set a password
because you're oing in so you didn't get
to set a password.
Right. Okay.
So the complexity is in the UI of image
flip.
Just thank you.
Yes. Absolutely. Let me know if you have
another issue. Yes.
So um in our testing like and also there
there's a public I think it's pretty
much flipped there's a public key that
floats around. So there is an anonymous
key that's public like get guardian will
flag. Others consider it a secret, but
apparently it's not and people are using
it. And the reason that we finally asked
people to make their username and
password is that it gets you a
significantly higher rate limit
and so you're less likely to run into
this issue in the workshop at least.
Yeah, the error
the what's the specific error you're
getting?
Is it opaque?
Actually, now I'm getting just
like cannot run. Oh, if you like are you
on the which branch are you on? Are you
okay? I think we're on two. We're on
two.
Mhm.
Yeah, I think so. Try doing get switch
and Yeah, two
stash all that stuff first. Yeah,
you have no idea the struggles of trying
to do a workshop with when API keys are
involved. Uh we originally had a step
that it would not it would take an
inspiration from an image flip image and
then generate a new meme. So it was a
completely unique meme. Uh but in order
to do that you would have to go in and
verify your OpenAI account which means
like you would have to scan your
passport to be able to do it. We thought
that might be a little much to ask in
this workshop.
Can um can you guys say more about like
how you're I guess like interacting with
these workflows and agents in the cases
you've seen, you said something about
Verscell, like are you deploying them
and then contacting them through like an
API call or like are they actually
embedded into your application?
Yeah. Um, what I'm primarily doing right
now is uh you still using the Verscelli
SDK. So everything I've got like at
least at work that's deployed already.
That's mostly Verscelli SDK and then
we're building a ton of like internal
tooling with master that started like
two three weeks ago
and most of our stuff goes to Verscell
um just because we already had that and
it's pretty fast. Um, and then most of
the things I've built so far are web
applications that might have a pipeline.
So there's a UI and there's still a user
kind of requesting generations and
asking for things.
Um, what I think would be super cool and
powerful though is like the the
workflows expose like an API endpoint to
just start them and hit them from
anything. And so I think that's also
like a pretty powerful pattern. I've not
really used it really fully right now in
prod yet, but that's um something I
would think about for sure. like cron
jobs almost workflows that need to run
like every night, you know, maybe have a
cron that fires that or something.
All right, cool. Thanks.
Yeah, great question.
All right, we got about five minutes and
then we're going to move to next step.
So, if anyone's stuck on anything or has
questions, don't be shy.
Does anybody have the memes generating
right now through the workflow?
All right. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12.
That's amazing.
Post some of your favorites in the in
the Slack.
Yeah.
Uh there's no filters left on them. So
yes,
if you like what happened, it's uh we
did it. And if you are offended, it's
not our fault. This is the when you're
dealing with memes like this, it really
brings out the non-determinism of of
this. If it generates offensive ones, we
tried to
to curb that, but also these AIs are not
great sometimes.
If people initiate want to raise their
hands, I'll go around and give you guys
if you want to. Yeah. A free signed. Are
we talking autographs here, Sam? Or
I'll autograph.
We're talking autographed copies. Are
they first edition or second edition?
Uh, first edition.
Autograph first edition from from the
CEO of Master Itself. If you got a meme
working and you want or you just want a
book, raise your hand.
Excellent.
That's pretty offensive.
Pretty offensive.
This this gentleman would like a book as
well.
Thank you.
Bible.
Yeah. I'm building agents in Typescript.
Got it.
Oh, these are all This is amazing.
Yeah, I got some pretty racy ones by
saying, "Why did they put a systems
engineer on an open floor plan with the
sales folks that are screaming all day?"
That's a fun prompt.
I love this.
That's awesome.
Every project.
Yes sir. So I come from a data
engineering background and there's
something called DAGs and Airflow which
are for whatever reason culturally
they've caught on. Um as you guys have
designed workflows have you thought of
DAGs? Are they similar dissimilar?
Are you talking about directed cyclic
graphs?
Yeah control. What does the control flow
look like for workflows?
So far stuff that I I've seen you know
supported by the semantics of like a a
master pipeline. Honestly, um to be
perfectly frank, the place that my mind
goes with that is just graph rag like
like a graph plus retrieval augmented
generation. So like some vector database
plus a graph knowledge graph to like do
traversal um to also answered like
structured questions about entities in
addition to like semantic search
capabilities. Um that's honestly what
I've built mostly or see seeing people
kind of like like positing is going to
be a nextgen architecture. But so far
what I've needed is just been pretty
simple pipelines. basically run these
steps branch over here if this happens.
Um,
you know, I see the DAG is like that's
like Terraform in my mind from from
DevOps like land of like it must proceed
this way and the entire thing fails if
if like node three is unhealthy kind of.
I see.
Yeah.
possible to trigger step four?
That's a great question. We were
actually Nick asked if we could trigger
a specific step. I'm not sure. But the
other thing I'll say is that in those
cases, that's the other reason I love
the pipelines and also even just the
concept of steps and agents because I
can do a specific model for each one. So
like extracting frustrations is like
that's pretty simple and should be fast
and cheap. So it's like do 40 or even
something simpler or maybe even get away
with like a seven billion parameter
model that's deployed on like Cloudflare
workers,
right? in which it's like essentially
free. Um that's like and that that
question by the way this is like the uh
like how do you right size AI
application workloads like that is top
of mind for everybody now. Everyone's
asking that questions like how to get
the infra to be what's correct for the
workload I have.
I think everyone's trying to figure that
out. Yeah.
And and another thing like you can
explore different ways of doing this. Uh
when we first started with this we had
all of these steps as tools
and then kind of let the AI decide when
it should call them. Um, so that could
be another approach depending on if it
can intelligently skip steps. Um, it
might be able to do that.
Um, there was a question is this is in
our chat, right?
Is is I'm looking. Okay. So there's a
question is is there a way to implement
or configure caching with master? I
think the answer is yes.
Yeah, for sure.
So
the same
show me the your N file you would
Yeah. Right.
That looks right to me. Assuming those
are your actual credits.
And then the other thing is did you uh
did you restart?
I I saved it and then I
password combination.
So it's
still
Oh, so restart it now because I bet you
did you update end while that was
running?
So, if you restart it, it should um pick
up the new end. Let's see if it's the
same or not.
Yep.
Yep. Exactly. Yep.
Bad food. Yeah. Nice.
I thought it was because it was two
words instead of one.
Am I still have a Is there an extra
space anywhere? And because I had that
issue even after I had the correct
values like there has to be.
Uh it'll take a a few weeks probably.
Oh no.
Is it not going through?
Did it try and execute the tool?
Yeah.
Uh what a different key.
What? Um
I don't think it's client or
AI.
This is it. It should be relatively
fast.
Second time trying. It's just
waiting for approval.
Ah okay. Uh good to know.
Let's try that.
We should
um so I can show this now.
Uh so if you go if you have it
installed, which I do. Um
down in here, I have MCP shop set up.
This is Claude, by the way. Uh hey, bro.
I hear I can get a shirt.
Let's see if it works. Should I do
install or
pondering t-shirt potential? That was
awesome.
Ah,
I can't provide physical shirts or
merchandise. That's interesting.
I thought you
should be connected.
Nope. That's the problem.
There we go.
Try that again.
Hey, bro. Here I can get a sweet MCP
shirt now that we're maybe connected.
Yeah.
Cool. So, it pops up.
We'll allow that.
[Music]
You can definitely get an MCP shirt.
There's one available right now. Here's
what you can get. Minimal design.
I don't know that it says context is
everything, but it might.
that.
Yeah.
Oh. Oh, yeah. Okay. It does.
Everything.
Yep.
Cool. Uh, so it just needs for me my
company name, my mailing address, and my
t-shirt size. So, I'll say Excel,
um, one infinite loop,
and company name, uh, Work OS.
Oh, it needs my city, state, and zip
code. I don't I don't know what that is
for Apple. Um, so I'll just I'm I live
in Omaha.
Oh, and look at that. It's going to buy
my shirt.
and it's ordered.
We will we will actually send you a
shirt. So, be be sure to
Yeah.
be sure to submit it while you're here.
You can also ask things like um can you
tell me about my order?
Uh it's deployed on is is this
you put it on cloud?
Yeah. Yeah. I have a version deployed on
Cloudflare. Um this one I think is it
might be
clcp shop. Yeah, probably in versell
I think it's yeah it's deployed to
Verscell um for this specific instance
of it. I I have a talk on Thursday where
I'm also I have the same thing deployed
to Cloudflare. So um we'll go into the
code and I can send out the repo for
that. But um
yes that one just saves it saves the
info to a KV store. Uh and then that's
that's what's used to order the shirts.
Uh you can deploy MCP servers to
Cloudflare now using work OS as the off
layer.
So feel free to check that out. We have
a blog post and a couple of tutorials.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's the thing. It's using work OS to
do that off. You didn't see it because
I'm already off in, but when I hit
connect, it opened up and it was do
completing that off flow to get me a
token so that I could uh do that here.
And you can see that in here it's got
like my order information.
Um,
I don't know.
Do you know my name and email, which is
totally not something I've said yet,
but but also to tie it again back
together, right? Because again, like
toy, it's fun. Got a t-shirt, but
imagine this as an e-commerce workflow,
right? This is what people are building.
Like, this is what everyone's trying to
figure out how to do correctly. What I
actually want to do is just go, I'm in a
hurry. I want to get on the page and
say, "It needs to be a product exactly
like this. Does it support that?" Okay,
fine. Go. not $40, less than that,
right? That's what everyone wants to do.
Um, and so that's what this interface
is.
Yeah. Pretty soon you'll be social
engineering your way through LLM's to
get a free shirt when it's not free.
Yep.
I can't wait for the future.
Uh, cool.
Yeah. Let's let's uh look at the
workflow. So, I switched over to the
step three branch, which is the end of
step two, uh, where you should be at.
And you've got a new meme generation
workflow. Uh, and it's got, you know, a
bunch of schemas set up for the input
and output schemas.
Uh, and all of the steps set up to run
each of these. And, you know, that's the
code for it. Let's go look at the the
actual get out of here. Um, the tools in
Maestra. So, I'll refresh this and go
back to work
workflows. There we go. Now, we have our
meme generation workflow and it's got
four steps. And so this is a little bit
better, a little little more detailed in
what what it's doing. Um, it's got not
including these mappings. It's got our
extract functions, find base meme,
generate captions, generate meme. Oh,
come on. Uh, and then a final mapping.
Um, and so I don't know. Someone give me
a work of frustration.
Somebody ate my sandwich out of the
fridge.
When no one in the workshop is
someone was too busy preparing a
workshop to review my PR,
Nick.
No, never.
And won't review my PR. That's a madeup
one. Um, so yeah, it can run. You can
see it running. Um, and then we can go.
We see all of the steps are now green.
And so we can see the input and debug
the input and output on each of the
steps. So there's the input that we got
and it gave out a frustration a
communication frustration
and oh I am all sorts of messing this
up.
Uh but we can have it find the base meme
and then generate the captions for it.
Find out what that is. So, when the
meeting could have been an email, but
everyone is just smiling like it's fine.
That's relatable. Um, but then down in
the generate meme one, that's going to
receive the captions. It's going to
receive apparently a meme called
disaster girl. And
did I mention that these are
nondeterministic? And I don't know what
it's going to generate.
Ah, the meeting could have been an
email, but everyone is just smiling like
it's fine. This is fine. Yeah. Um, yeah.
So, this is fun, right? We can see the
workflows, the inputs and outputs of it,
and we can debug those steps along the
way. We can see exactly what is what
we're starting with and how it
progresses through each of the steps uh
to give us a full workflow, which is
awesome. Um,
we haven't even had to do a deployment
yet. and we can just iterate locally,
change the prompts, change the schemas
until you get it exactly the way you
want and then you haven't wasted time
going back and forth. You've like
iterated rapidly.
Yeah.
And so really easy debugging. That's why
we love this tool. Like it's it's just
really fun and easy to do. So in the
final step, um the the final main step
we have, uh we're going to like take
that workflow now and call it with an
agent. So this is a pretty
straightforward step. We're just going
to create an agent, give it a prompt to
work with, and give it the the knowledge
of the this workflow that it can run,
and then it'll run it for us. So,
instead of having to use that interface,
we can use a chat interface uh that
we're more familiar with and go from
there.
And so, and again, to tie it back to
actually taking this home and doing
something useful with it, like we've
gotten to the point where we've
described a workflow of steps that
completes a discrete task. and maybe
that's something that our our co-orker
needs and then again maybe they are
technical maybe they're not maybe
they're just in a hurry. So by building
them an agent and saying use this
workflow and you you have the ability to
call this workflow that becomes an ideal
interface to give to our colleagues to
start using this and then something that
they used to have to do peacemilly
they're just now firing off a chat
request and it's done for them
automatically.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So with this you'll learn
what agents are, how you give them
instructions, um the memory systems for
them, the workflow integration uh
through Mastra, and then how you can
test them in the playground.
Wow, these are awesome. So, these are
new community memes pouring in in real
time.
We finally catch up on Slack messages.
There's already 20 more waiting. Nice.
Yeah, that's a great idea. Yeah,
there's some great um feedback on the
framework guys in the in the Slack
channel. There's like some UX requests
as well. You see,
that's great.
too real.
You can also play with the uh prompt uh
the props a little bit to tweak it about
what it's how it's like analyzing the
frustration, the level of frustration,
the type of meme, um things like that.
It's really fun to get a a vibe for it.
Yeah, indeed.
All right. Is everyone more or less have
uh what they need? Is anyone still stuck
on anything? Last minute questions or
pickups?
No. Cool.
That's amazing. I make a t-shirt with
that.
Uh just a I guess a comment from us and
I guess from the team as well like
honestly like thanks everybody for
coming and building these. We didn't
even know this workshop was happening
until last week. It was but um I mean
previously like so like most of us at
MRA were previously building Gatsby like
I was the co-founder and so we've been
doing open source JavaScript stuff for a
while but it's like pretty humbling when
you show up for a conference and
actually someone else is giving a
workshop about how to use the thing that
you built. Um and I think I speak for
all of us. So like thanks everybody.
Thanks a lot.
Thanks.
It's been a pleasure.
[Applause]
And on the same side, we didn't know
that you were going to be here until I
think like yesterday,
but you got very excited because it's
like, hey, you got a question about
commit. Let's go.
I'm just personally curious how many
folks have or like already have agents
deployed at work in prod that they're
using for things. only a couple how many
folks are trying to get them in into
prod right now.
I'd be curious to know what you're using
them for.
Yeah, I'd also be curious if anyone
wants to share either in the Slack or
just call it out or come up to Mike like
what are the top use cases that you're
thinking of for agents or struggling
with. I'd be curious to know too. This
is such a fun time because there's like
like you you have to get your head
around what it's doing and then get your
head around what it can do and it just
it starts to feel like the possibilities
are endless and just super fun.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
We have servers.
Yep.
That's awesome.
Yeah, that's awesome. So, like you've
got um so you want to be able to chat
with your infrastructure and like ask
questions like either an incident like
show up to the incident and even already
have like initial guesses maybe.
Yeah, that's awesome.
Cool. Any other use cases?
I think that we're finding um we're
mostly able to just knock out a ton of
like lowhanging fruit that folks are
doing manually right now. It's, you
know, especially with tools like this,
like you, you know, create a simple
agent or even just a pipeline with a few
steps and couple API calls and that can
like free up hours of somebody's week.
Um I think that's the part that I'm most
excited about right now.
Yeah, it's like all the little paper
cuts. you can just so quickly iterate on
them and get things going.
And not just with the these tools, but
just like vibe coding in general. Like
you can, you know, be like, I'm going to
spend an hour just seeing where I can
get to. And
yeah, it's amazing.
Incredible how quickly you can get
there.
Always review the code though. Please.
What's that?
Always review the code, please.
Yeah, please review the code. Use tools
like Git Guardian before you commit.
Yeah.
Yeah, we had our our AI
moment uh a couple weeks ago at our last
on site and uh we had like a couple
hours just to spend doing something with
AI and it there was really no
prescription to it. is just explore and
play and if you can solve a problem
great if not you learned something along
the way and uh the thing that I worked
on was like m as the maintainer of
several SDKs across several languages uh
a pain point I saw was like people
adding in you know very simple PRs to
one repo that's like the node repo the
node SDK and then doing the same thing
it's like adding a new field to the node
SDK and then adding the same field to
the Ruby Go PHP cotlin all of the SDKs.
I was like, I wonder if we could do
something to alleviate that and make it
easier. And after two hours of pure vibe
coding with Claude, I had a GitHub
action that when you label the first PR
that you do, you just add a label to it,
it will go and generate the PRs for
every other repo
and automatically PR
every other SDK.
Yep.
It's awesome. Were you using like a
software engineering
or something?
Making the Oh, that's a great question.
Making the changes is one thing. And
that's something that Yeah, I think
Dagger would make a lot of sense, but
what were you doing with that?
I wasn't I wasn't doing any of that. Um
I've coded it and I actually don't know
what the code does.
He and he had that
I didn't review it.
He had a 4,300 line GitHub action that's
working great. how
I want to hear more about that.
But to be clear, we didn't ship it. Uh
it's it's an experiment. Maybe maybe we
will for sure. Um but the week after
that, I think um Claude had come out
with like be the ability to run cloud
code as a uh like via an API so that you
could like spin it up, run it, give it
the instructions on what to do, and then
let it figure out how to do it because
like most of the code that it generated
was just handling how it was going to do
the diffs. And for several hours of
that, it was just like it made the
changes I wanted and then deleted the
rest of the files. And that wasn't
great, you know.
Um, we're also, for what it's worth,
finding uh incredible utility with tools
like Vzero Dev. So, if you're already in
the Verscell ecosystem or used Nex.js,
JS there's now they're they were
originally conceived of as like rapid
prototyping tools that maybe for
designers or maybe for developers but
like an example is that somebody on our
marketing and sales team is trying to
figure out who would be interesting
engineers are already doing work with
MCP to contact about conferences like
this and their workflow is completely
manual and they're you know talking to
me about it on a on a call and four
minutes after they started telling me
about it I had it working like in vzero
dev and hand it to them and they had a
completely separate you know tool that's
available and URL that they can just
paste in whatever they need essentially
and get like the analysis done. Um, and
so that was very eye opening for me
because it's in some cases now it's
faster to create the tool that your
colleague needs than it is to continue
talking about the tool that your
colleague needs and even ticketing it or
saying next Tuesday we should try and
like sometimes you can literally sit
down in vzero dev with like a paragraph
very descript and get what you need.
Nice. That's pretty good.
Yes.
No,
not in my experience. Not yet.
Yeah, totally. I think that's that's a
fascinating question. Yeah. The question
is like when um folks in other roles
that are not traditionally technical see
how quickly you can scaffold this stuff,
are they all clamoring for the keyboard?
That's not been my experience yet there.
I think that's also like part of what
the trepidation and anxiety is around is
like, well, now everyone can do it. But
then I also comfort myself and say that
I define a pleasurable evening as like
sitting down for 12 hours on one of
these machines and going back and forth
to try and get it to go the way I want.
And that's not most people's description
of a fun time. So like even when the
tools are better, I I still think you
kind of have to find this enjoyable. You
know what I mean? I don't I don't I I I
I think it might change to some degree
like when like most generation becomes
oneshotable
and you say I want this app and it's of
like this complexity and most people can
get something working immediately.
That's correct. I think that'll take a
lot of low hanging fruit off but
they would do what
And then they
almost
tell me.
Yeah, I I think that's super
fascinating. And anecdotally, um, it's
mostly been lawyers when I've been at
meetups that have come up and asked the
most like salient questions about Genaii
and they'll say like, "I'm not a coder,
but like this is what we're trying to
do." Also, semantic search and all like
the information compression that's
available with a lot of the Genai tools
like I think uniquely speaks to their
use case too of there's this gigantic
corpus of case law and need to know
exactly this right now. Right. Yeah.
It's but it is um it's an intense time I
think for that reason. Yeah. Culturally,
right?
less than 20 minutes.
What are we doing? Nothing.
uh in this uh session or in general
sorry I didn't right now uh no yeah but
uh I have a I have a
yeah yeah yeah for the the most part. I
have a tutorial for you that does that
if you want it.
Thanks. Thanks for coming. Appreciate
it.
Yeah.
All right. So, we can show the agent
piece of it now. Um, so I switched over
to the step four branch, uh, which is
the end of step three, uh, where we
should have the created, uh, agent now
that can run, uh, and actually have a
conversation with the tooling, uh, which
makes it really a lot easier to work
with. Uh, but we still have the power of
being able to use the workflow tool to
see what's going on and debug the steps
along the way. Uh, but now if we go to
the agents tab in Maestro, we've got a
meme generator and this gives us a very
sim very familiar look and feel. Gives
us a chat window. Uh, but it gives us
more than that. In the uh the sidebar
here, we've got an overview. We can see
the instructions uh that are given to
the agent. So, it's a helpful UI agent.
uh or AI agent that's going to help us
do that. Uh it's got some critical steps
in there. It's got the workflow that it
should follow um and telling it what it
has access to. We also can see the model
settings and we can adjust this as we
go. So, we can add more or less
temperature uh top P. We can change all
of these on the fly and test it to
really hone in on like what works best
for whatever we're trying to build. So,
I'll ask one more time. Work
frustration. Who's got the gnarliest
work? Who's the most frustrated at work
right now? Raise your hand. And again,
you must state your company and your
immediate superior's name.
Um, I always get asked to go to large
meetings for 4 hours and then uh I don't
speak at all.
This bothers you too. I see.
Yes.
Meeting fatigue. Um, so now we can just
ask the chat and see the output and it's
much cleaner. It'll actually give us the
image in line too. um which makes it
really nice and easy to
work with that pointless meeting I was
dragged into.
But if you scroll up a little bit too,
the other thing uh to see here is like
so the user asked a question and you saw
that the workflow got run. Um but now
there's also additionally like the agent
is still chatting and it's in a familiar
way that you already are familiar with
if you use GPT. Um but then again just a
reminder that this is kind of the ideal
interface for uh folks that might be
your clients or your customers or your
colleagues.
Yep. And we can see like inline what
happened you know the tool arguments
that were passed in the total result. We
can see what tools were called uh and
how in this case it was the workflow and
here's all of the information and then
the end result that we can actually play
with.
Yeah. So this could be, you know, a
chatbot that someone is uh requesting a
report from, an analysis, a SQL query,
uh new code, a review of code, review of
a design, like a new image. Uh you can
kind of put whatever you want behind the
same interface.
Not really. Not really.
[Laughter]
It's non-deterministic, guys.
Um,
there's there's no HR for this
conference.
I was told that in advance. So, uh, kind
of to wrap that up, uh, what we built
was a multi-step workflow that we could
give to a conversational agent who knows
how to execute it, knows what to pass
into it and what it's going to get back
and then it can do with that what it
will. It gave us, you know, human
feedback. Uh, wasn't just spitting out
JSON in the end. Uh, it was giving us an
actual response and then showing us the
image inline and giving us a clickable
link so that we could go share that
image uh, to whoever we wanted to. Um,
and we were able to create some awesome
memes. I highly recommend you deploy
this and use it because it's cathartic
to really vent to it. Um, and if you're
deploying it, the your data is safe
probably. I don't know. Find out there.
So some key takeaways uh from this uh we
learned about the workflows agents we uh
type safety um catching errors in that
uh and the structured generation to
ensure a reliable output uh and some of
the benefits of master.
Yep. Um, also just say that the we don't
show this here, but one of the examples
that's on master site you can go check
out is like a 37 line of code uh
pipeline that does retrieval augmented
generation. And if you've worked if
you've built those pipelines before,
like two years ago, you know, you had to
glue together at least three or four
libraries. It was a super crappy
experience. Um, so it's just really nice
to have a single place you can go and
define that pipeline at a high level.
Um, so yeah, excited to experiment more
with that as well.
There's a ton here that you can do that
we did not even scratch the surface of
or point to yet.
Yeah, for sure. Coming up with what to
do in two hours. It's uh not a lot of
time
and there's a lot a lot more that we
could dig into and we highly encourage
you to. So, this was meant as a
a primer. Uh you you have like an
example. Yeah.
Yeah.
Uh now experiment with it. Add things,
add tools, um deploy it with MCP, like
figure out
with your co-workers. Yeah.
Yeah.
Ask them to use it. See what happens.
So yeah, explore the tool creation, uh
add a vector database, implement rag, uh
all of those. And just a final reminder,
uh mcp.shop,
um go order a t-shirt, check it out. Uh
it's really cool.
So thank you with that. Um we've got 15
minutes left. We wanted to save that for
questions. Any uh additional followup?
Any just general casual conversation
about these tools? Uh the fascinating
world of AI, anything?
Vote on memes that were generated and
see who is the ultimate winner in the
Slack channel.
So, I'm giving a talk on agents and
workflows tomorrow and I really liked
your agents and workflows side. Can you
bring them up again?
What? I didn't hear what you said.
Yeah, I didn't hear it. Sorry.
Oh, sorry. I'm giving a talk on agents
and workflows tomorrow. Agents and
workflow sites were really good. Can you
bring them up again?
Sure, we can share them, too. They're
open source because they're in our repo
and they're on Markdown.
There's a couple tools that Nick Nick
likes.
Uh yeah, this was slide slide dev or
slide.dev.
Um,
yeah, it was something that we switched
to relatively not that long ago.
20 minutes before this talk pretty much.
Yeah.
Uh, questions for us or the master team?
Uh, do make sure that you if you want a
shirt, buy a shirt because we will
actually send you a shirt. We might not
send it this week, but uh we're tracking
all the orders and we're going to honor
all of them. So, it's a limited edition
MCP. Shop shirt that will never be seen
again.
Yep.
If you want official master book, um
autographed copies are $30, right?
And otherwise
Cool. Um, yeah. Yeah. Question.
Where's the memory and execution step?
The memory and execution tab. Um, yeah.
So, you can configure, you know, we we
configured SQLite for this demo and
that's what's powering like the ability
as you create additional chats, you'll
see the previous chats on the left rail.
Um, but there's a ton of different
storage drivers like there's the
Postgress and everything else, right?
Um, so you can basically choose what you
need to. Um, and then once you configure
memory, you pass it into either the
workflow or agent. Um, and then that's
by by way of doing that, you're telling
it can use it essentially. Is that your
question?
The demo one doesn't have memory.
The demo one does have memories using
SQLite. And it's
I saw it says check executions tab.
Where do I find that?
Uh, check execution tab. Where you let
me I'll come over.
Oh, thank you. Thanks so much for
coming. I appreciate it.
And uh yeah, we'll be around uh all week
uh at the conference. So reach out. Uh
we'd love to chat more.
Thank you.
[Music]